[Music]
i'm kean kaplan
as a neuroscientist living with
tourette's ocd and adhd
i study what makes my brain different
from the average person
growing up i struggled academically and
socially
paying attention sitting still and
waiting my turn were everyday challenges
in the classroom and i was definitely
bullied a lot
it wasn't until i was 14 when i watched
a documentary about tourette's and
realized
holy i have that
my life changed the moment i was
diagnosed by a neurologist
the doctors gave me a word for what i
was experiencing but they still couldn't
explain why it was happening or how to
make it stop
why can't i control the movements and
sounds i make why aren't there better
treatments for people like me
these are the questions that inspired me
to pursue a career in neuroscience
yes it's been hard but nobody
understands the experiences and
challenges of brain disorders better
than the people living with them we need
neurodiverse people to study the brain
because our perspectives are critical to
scientific progress both in the lab and
society